This is 99% Invisible. I'm Roman Mars. On the campus of Florida International University in Miami, there's a place ominously named the Extreme Events Institute. They do things like map the risk of storm surge for the whole Caribbean and study how the public perceives the threat from natural disasters. They're also home to the International Hurricane Research Center. And right there, next to a parking lot in front of an open field, they have this huge bright blue airplane hanger. That's producer Alana Casanova-Bergis.
这里是 99% Invisible。我是罗曼·马斯。在迈阿密佛罗里达国际大学的校园里，有一个名字听起来很不祥的地方，叫做极端事件研究所。他们从事的工作包括绘制整个加勒比地区的风暴潮风险地图，以及研究公众如何看待自然灾害的威胁。这里也是国际飓风研究中心的所在地。就在那里，紧邻露天场地的停车场旁，他们有一个巨大的亮蓝色飞机机库。那是制作人阿拉娜·卡萨诺瓦-伯吉斯。
All right. Here I am. Written across the massive closed doors in big baby blue letters, it says W-O-W, wow, which stands for wall of wind. Hi. Hello. They let you in, huh? Eric Salna, a meteorologist who works here, takes me inside the closed hanger.
好了。我到了。巨大且紧闭的大门上用婴儿蓝的大字写着 W-O-W，wow，也就是“风墙”的缩写。嗨。你好。他们让你进来了，对吧？埃里克·萨尔纳是一位在这里工作的气象学家，他带我进入了紧闭的机库内。
He notices the recorder I'm holding and the mic I have shoved in his face. Your hands are full. I was going to let you have the unique experience of opening one of the doors. I could, I could. Look, look. He passes me a metal box with a big button. So you're going to press that open. Okay. And I kind of get the sense he does this with a lot of visitors.
他注意到了我手里拿着的录音机，以及塞在他脸前的麦克风。你的手真忙。我原本想让你体验一下亲手打开其中一扇门的独特感受。我可以的，我可以的。看，看。他递给我一个带有大按钮的金属盒。所以你要按下那个打开。好的。我有一种感觉，他经常对许多访客这么做。
Okay, three, two, one. Okay, three, two, one. The doors slide open and all that Florida sunshine streams into the hangar, illuminating a wall of a dozen giant yellow fans stacked in two rows of six. Yeah, so there you go. What do you think? Wow. Literally. That's what everyone says, never fails. Each fan is six feet in diameter. They were originally made for ventilating mining shafts,
好的，三，二，一。好的，三，二，一。大门缓缓拉开，佛罗里达的阳光倾泻进机库，照亮了一堵由十几个巨大黄色风扇组成的墙，它们排成两行，每行六个。好了，这就是了。你觉得怎么样？哇。字面意思上的。每个人都这么说，屡试不爽。每个风扇的直径都有六英尺。它们最初是为通风矿井巷道制造的，
but engineers here have figured out how to get them to make hurricane strength winds. And that's why I'm here, because this is a lab where researchers are figuring out how we can make our homes and infrastructure survive hurricanes better, especially at a time when more intense storms are going to be more frequent. What shape should a roof be so it stands a better chance of not getting blown off? Is it possible to make stronger doors?
但这里的工程师们已经摸索出如何让它们产生飓风强度的风。这就是我来这里的原因，因为这是一个实验室，研究人员正在这里寻找如何让我们的房屋和基础设施更好地抵御飓风的方法，尤其是在更强烈的风暴将更加频繁出现的时代。屋顶应该是什么形状，才能有更大几率不被风吹掀？有可能制造出更坚固的门吗？
What's the best kind of screw to use? — When they used to make rooftops, they would use a nail, nice and smooth. So when a wind comes, it gets pulled right out. Well, what we developed here was a nail that looks like a screw. Now, if you put it into that wood, it's not going to get pulled out. — You're yanking your finger and it's not moving. — It's not moving. — Okay. Everyone I met for this story bragged about
最好使用哪种螺丝？——过去他们制作屋顶时，会使用钉子，又光滑又好。所以当风吹来时，它直接就被拔出来了。嗯，我们在这里开发的是一种看起来像螺丝的钉子。现在，如果你把它钉进那木头里，它是不会被拔出来的。——你拽着你的手指，它没动。——没动。——好的。我为这个故事采访的每个人都在夸耀
how South Florida, which braces for hurricanes every summer, has adopted some of the toughest building codes in the country. And they're updated regularly, so new building methods get factored in. It's now required that all roofs use these special nails, based on research done here at the Wall of Wind. When all 12 fans are going full blast, this lab can test different construction methods against winds as high as 157 miles per hour. Hurricanes that strong are incredibly rare. They've only made landfall in the U.S. four times. One of them happened right here.
南佛罗里达州每个夏天都要为飓风做准备，并已经采纳了全美最严格的建筑法规。而且它们会定期更新，因此新的建筑方法被纳入其中。现在，所有屋顶都必须使用这些基于“风墙”研究成果的特殊钉子。当所有 12 个风扇全速运转时，这个实验室可以测试各种建筑方法对高达每小时 157 英里风力的抗击能力。如此强烈的飓风极其罕见。它们在全美登陆过的次数只有四次。其中一次就发生在这里。
Everyone here in South Florida, if you were down here, it's a memory that you'll never forget. Hurricane Andrew made landfall in 1992, just south of downtown Miami. Andrew had sustained winds of 165 miles per hour, destroying at least 50,000 homes, ripping some of them right off of their foundations. It was the costliest disaster in US history at the time. Changed everything. Changed emergency management.
南佛罗里达的每个人，如果你当时在这里，那将是一段你永远不会忘记的记忆。安德鲁飓风于 1992 年登陆，就在迈阿密市中心的正南方。安德鲁拥有每小时 165 英里的持续风速，摧毁了至少 5 万栋房屋，甚至将其中一些直接从地基上扯了下来。这是当时美国历史上损失最惨重的灾难。改变了一切。改变了应急管理。
Changed research. Changed the building codes. All of those things were accelerated after Hurricane Andrew. Meteorologists designated Hurricane Andrew a so-called category 5 storm. Even if you don't know much about hurricanes, you know a category 5 is major. It's actually the highest classification according to the scale we use to measure these
改变了研究。改变了建筑法规。所有这些都在安德鲁飓风之后加速推进了。气象学家将安德鲁飓风指定为所谓的 5 级风暴。即使你对飓风了解不多，你也知道 5 级是一场重大灾难。事实上，根据我们用来衡量这些事情的尺度，这是最高的分类。
things. The Saffir-Simpson Hurricane Wind Scale. For 50 years, the Saffir-Simpson Scale has been used to talk about how to build more resilient communities. It's been the language that we all rely on to understand what kind of risk a hurricane poses. During storm emergencies, we are primed to hear about categories. And the scale has transcended hurricanes.
萨菲尔-辛普森飓风风力等级。50 年来，萨菲尔-辛普森等级一直被用于探讨如何建设更具韧性的社区。它一直是我们赖以理解飓风构成何种风险的语言。在风暴紧急情况下，我们已经习惯了听闻各种级别。而这个等级已经超越了飓风本身。
It's been adopted as a common shorthand for describing damage of all kinds. We use it for situations that have absolutely nothing to do with weather. — Midterm madness, more like a category four hurricane. — We're now treating this like a massive cat five hurricane disaster. — Homeland Security Secretary Nielsen there, sounding the alarm on the immigration crisis ahead of— — Donald Trump is a cat five disaster for American political discourse. The reason the Saffir-Simpson scale has been adapted so much is because it's really good at what it does. It's a clear, easy shorthand for damage.
它已被采纳为描述各种伤害的通用简写。我们将其用于与天气完全无关的情况。——期中疯狂，更像是一场 4 级飓风。——我们现在正将此视同为一场大规模的 5 级飓风灾难。——国土安全部长尼尔森在那里就即将到来的移民危机拉响警报————唐纳德·特朗普对美国政治话语体系来说是一场 5 级灾难。萨菲尔-辛普森等级之所以被如此广泛地调整使用，是因为它在所做的事情上非常出色。它是一种关于损失的清晰、简单的简写。
It tells us what we can expect from different categories of hurricane strength winds, what they're likely to do to our homes, to our infrastructure, and our communities. It's a snapshot of probable impact. The thing is, five decades on, we've got different homes, different infrastructure, different communities. Scientists say even our hurricanes are different these days. And there are doubts now about whether the Saffir-Simpson scale is telling us enough in that snapshot and whether it still serves this changing world we live in.
它告诉我们，我们可以从不同级别的飓风强度风力中预期什么，它们可能会对我们的家园、基础设施和社区造成什么影响。它是可能造成影响的快照。问题是，五十年过去了，我们有了不同的家园、不同的基础设施、不同的社区。科学家们表示，如今连我们的飓风都变了。现在人们开始怀疑，萨菲尔-辛普森等级在那个快照中是否向我们提供足够的信息，以及它是否仍然服务于我们生活的这个不断变化的世界。
Because hurricanes are so chaotic, they've always been a bit tricky to characterize, even in an age of satellites and radar. They're capricious. They can get stronger or weaker and change direction quickly. No two are the same. And even a single hurricane isn't uniform all the way around. They have a stronger side and a weaker one. You know, hurricanes are facts of nature. The best that we can do is forecast them,
因为飓风具有极大的混乱性，它们一直有点难以描述，即使在卫星和雷达时代也是如此。它们变化无常。它们可能会变强或变弱，并迅速改变方向。没有哪两个飓风是相同的。甚至单一飓风在四周也不是均匀的。它们有一侧更强，另一侧更弱。你知道，飓风是大自然的客观事实。我们能做的最好的事情就是预测它们、
monitor them, understand them, and react to them when they do approach and then deal with the aftermath once they've left. Eric J. Dolan is the author of A Furious Sky, the 500-year history of America's hurricanes. For a lot of that history, Hurricanes were almost mystical events. The hand of God made manifest. Modern forecasting didn't exist until the mid-19th century. Before that, the hand of God made manifest. Modern forecasting didn't exist until the mid 19th century. Before that, the Taino, who were among the original inhabitants of the Caribbean, taught colonizers how to tell one was coming.
监测它们、理解它们，并在它们逼近时做出反应，然后在它们离开后处理善后工作。埃里克·J·多兰是《汹涌的天空：美国飓风五百年史》一书的作者。在很长一段时间里，飓风几乎是神秘莫测的事件。上帝之手的具象化。现代预报直到 19 世纪中叶才出现。在此之前，上帝之手的具象化。现代预报直到 19 世纪中叶才出现。在此之前，作为加勒比地区最早居民之一的泰诺人，教导殖民者如何辨别飓风的到来。
There were small advances in understanding the basics of how they worked, but it wasn't until the 1870s that observers began to accurately predict where that hurricane was coming from and going to and how destructive it might be when it got there. That big leap forward came from a Jesuit working out of a coastal observatory in Havana, Cuba. His name was Father Benito Víñez, but he was also known as the Hurricane Priest. The observatory had decades worth of observations. So he read through them, collected them, systematized them.
在理解其运作原理的基本方面曾取得过一些小进展，但直到 19 世纪 70 年代，观察员们才开始准确预测飓风从何而来、去往何处，以及到达时可能会具有多大的破坏力。这一巨大飞跃源于一位在古巴哈瓦那海岸天文台工作的耶稣会士。他的名字叫本尼托·比涅斯神父，但他也被称为飓风神父。该天文台拥有数十年的观测资料。于是他研读了这些资料，将其收集并系统化。
And he had plenty of equipment, even some he invented himself. He would take up to 10 measurements a day, different kinds of measurements, barometric measurements, precipitation, temperature. And he was really into watching clouds. Those were the wispy cirrostratus clouds. He called them cat's tails, coxplumes, wind feathers. And these clouds were followed by more denser clouds, cumulostratus and then cumulonimbus.
而且他有充足的设备，甚至有些是他自己发明的。他每天会进行多达 10 次测量，各种不同类型的测量，气压测量、降水、温度。他非常热衷于观察云层。那些是纤细的卷层云。他称它们为猫尾、公鸡羽毛、风之羽。这些云之后会跟着更密集的云，层积云，然后是积雨云。
These were all clues that he could use to predict where bad weather was coming from and headed to. So he was able to develop a very intimate understanding of hurricanes and how they behaved. And he put together a fairly impressive record of predictions that was more than just chance. Father Vignes set up a telegraph network for hurricane news from across the Caribbean. He made forecasts for the entire region that were printed in newspapers and eagerly read. It blew people's minds that someone could forecast the path of these storms with such precision. The hurricane priest didn't always get it right. Still, he and his Cuban colleagues developed an international reputation with their hurricane
这些都是他用来预测恶劣天气从何而来、去往何处的线索。因此，他能够对飓风及其行为方式产生非常深刻的理解。他整理了一份相当令人印象深刻的预测记录，这不仅仅是靠运气。比涅斯神父建立了一个电报网络，用于收集来自整个加勒比地区的飓风新闻。他为整个地区制作了预报，这些预报被印在报纸上并受到热切阅读。有人能以如此高的精度预测这些风暴的路径，这让人们大开眼界。飓风神父并非总能预测正确。尽管如此，他和他的古巴同事凭借飓风警告在国际上树立了声誉。
warnings. Even after Father Vignes died in 1893, Cuba's forecasts were more accurate compared to the ones from other countries. In contrast, the U.S. system was sluggish and conservative. Meteorologists around the country had to wire their reports to Washington, D.C., where the central office would decide what was real and worth sharing. Warnings went out slowly, if at all. So the public was frequently caught off guard when big storms arrived.
甚至在比涅斯神父于 1893 年去世后，古巴的预报与来自其他国家的预报相比也更加准确。相比之下，美国的系统则迟缓而保守。全国各地的气象学家不得不将他们的报告拍电报发往华盛顿特区，由中央办公室决定什么是真实的、值得分享的。警告发布得很慢，甚至根本没有。因此，当大风暴来临时，公众常常措手不及。
And the Weather Bureau's Caribbean weather station was run by a guy who thought tracking hurricanes was, quote, a matter of divination. And then things got worse. In 1898, at the end of the Spanish-American War, the US took temporary control of Cuba, which meant the Americans took control of Cuba's warning systems. And instead of cooperating with their colleagues in the Caribbean, the Weather Bureau restricted access to telegraph cables
而且气象局的加勒比气象站由一个人管理，他认为追踪飓风“纯粹是一种占卜”。接着情况变得更糟。1898 年，美西战争结束时，美国暂时接管了古巴，这意味着美国人控制了古巴的预警系统。美国气象局不仅没有与加勒比地区的同行合作，反而限制了对电报电缆的使用，
and promoted their own West Indian hurricane warning systems instead. And a lot of that, as I described in the book, really had to do with the condescending attitude that the American meteorologists had towards their fellow meteorologists. And that was much the detriment of the Americans. They paid the price almost immediately.
转而推广他们自己的西印度群岛飓风预警系统。正如我在书中所描述的那样，这在很大程度上与美国气象学家对其他气象学家抱有的那种居高临下的态度有关。这极大地损害了美国人自身的利益。他们几乎立刻就付出了代价。
In September of 1900, Cuban meteorologists warned of a storm that was going to intensify, turn into a hurricane, and head to the Gulf of Mexico. And the Americans were not paying attention to the valuable meteorological information that the Cubans were providing providing and they missed some of the signs and information that the Cubans had been tracking. They knew that it was a hurricane. It wasn't until the very last moment that the American meteorologists finally said, oh this is a hurricane. By then it was almost too late. Galveston's population was 38,000 people at the time, and as many as 8,000 people died.
1900 年 9 月，古巴气象学家发出警告，称一场风暴将会加剧、变成飓风，并直奔墨西哥湾。而美国人却没有重视古巴人提供的宝贵气象信息，他们漏掉了古巴人一直在追踪的一些迹象和信息。他们知道这是一场飓风。直到最后一刻，美国气象学家才终于说，哦，这是一场飓风。到那时已经几乎太迟了。加尔维斯顿当时的人口为 38,000 人，多达 8,000 人丧生。
It's one thing to know generally that a storm is coming. It's another to forecast that it's going to be a deadly calamity. And it would be decades before the U.S. began making real progress in understanding hurricanes. That big leap came from a pair of cocky World War II pilots. The two airmen, also in Galveston, as it happens, made a bet to show how tough their planes were. And this was taking a plane, deliberately flying it into a hurricane, through the wall of a hurricane, into the eye of the hurricane.
笼统地知道风暴即将来临是一回事。预测它将是一场致命的灾难则是另一回事。美国需要几十年时间才能在理解飓风方面取得实质性进展。那个巨大的飞跃来自两名趾高气扬的二战飞行员。这两名飞行员碰巧也在加尔维斯顿，他们打了个赌，以展示他们的飞机有多坚固。他们驾驶一架飞机，蓄意飞进飓风中，穿过飓风壁，进入飓风眼。
If the plane could make it, they'd get a highball. They described the flight as being tossed around like a stick in a dog's mouth, but they did make it. And when they landed, a meteorologist from the base asked to go up next, and it caught on. The stunt turned into science. The hurricane priest, Fr. Vignes, would have probably loved this. By the early 1950s, these pilots and scientists form a cadre called Hurricane Hunters.
如果飞机能挺过去，他们就能喝到高球鸡尾酒。他们将这次飞行形容为像狗嘴里的一根棍子一样被抛来抛去，但他们确实成功了。当他们着陆时，基地的一位气象学家请求下一次也上去，随后这种做法便流行开来。这个特技演变成了科学。飓风神父比涅斯大概会很喜欢这个。到 20 世纪 50 年代初，这些飞行员和科学家组成了一个被称为“飓风猎人”的骨干队伍。
They would fly directly into swirling storms, which gave them an unprecedented ability to observe hurricanes close up. And instruments on board the planes would take measurements that could be relayed back to a land-based meteorologist or weather station with all of this data that can then be used by the meteorologist to help predict the path and strength of the hurricane.
他们会直接飞进旋转的风暴中，这赋予了他们前所未有的近距离观察飓风的能力。飞机上的仪器会进行测量，这些测量数据可以传回给陆基气象学家或气象站，所有这些数据随后可被气象学家用来帮助预测飓风的路径和强度。
But we still didn't have a way to communicate that forecast clearly and concisely, or a way to show the public what warnings were actually based on to prove that they were worth heeding. That step was taken by the most trusted voice in broadcasting at the time, Edward R. Murrow. — In mid-September of 1954, he decided to hop into a Hurricane Hunter plane and go and fly into the center of what was called Hurricane Edna, which was threatening the East Coast. Good evening.
但我们仍然缺乏一种清晰、简明地传达该预报的方法，或者缺乏一种向公众展示预警实际依据的方法，以证明它们值得关注。这一步是由当时广播界最受信赖的声音爱德华·R·默罗迈出的。——1954 年 9 月中旬，他决定跳上一架“飓风猎人”飞机，飞进被称为“埃德娜”飓风（当时正威胁着东海岸）的中心。晚上好。
This tattered hunk of cloth is a hurricane flag. 1954 was an active year for hurricanes, and Edna was big news. Murrow showed the country what it was like to track a hurricane's path toward landfall. This wasn't a stunt, Murrow showed the country what it was like to track a hurricane's path toward landfall. This wasn't a stunt, Murrow told viewers. It was a routine mission, a service from the United States Air Force to the United States taxpayer. Murrow, his cameraman and a small flight crew, climbed into a B-29 fighter plane, along with one meteorologist. And there was Murrow, trying to improve the public's understanding. The general opinion up here seems to be that Edna is not going to behave like a lady, but we will find out about that.
这块破烂不堪的布料是一面飓风旗。1954 年是飓风活跃的一年，“埃德娜”是个大新闻。默罗向全国展示了追踪飓风登陆路径是怎样一种体验。这不是一场特技，默罗向全国展示了追踪飓风登陆路径是怎样一种体验。这不是一场特技，默罗告诉观众。这是一项例行任务，是美国空军对美国纳税人的一项服务。默罗、他的摄影师和一个小型机组人员登上一架 B-29 战斗机，同行的还有一位气象学家。默罗就在那里，试图提高公众的理解。这里的普遍看法似乎是，“埃德娜”不会表现得像个淑女，但我们会拭目以待。
The general opinion up here, and that's in the Hurricane Hunter plane, seems to be that Edna is not going to behave like a lady. It's very 1950-ish. And then the plane goes into the eyewall. Murrow was showing the whole country, including parts far from the coasts, what the immense power of the storms looked like close up. What he describes into his microphone, above the roar of the engines and the storm, without even reading from a script, is beautiful. Being in the eye was like being in an amphitheater surrounded by clouds. No sign of the sun except this dim illumination.
高空的普遍看法（也就是在“飓风猎人”飞机上）似乎是，“埃德娜”不会表现得像个淑女。这非常具有 50 年代的色彩。随后飞机进入了眼壁。默罗向全国各地（包括远离海岸的地区）展示了风暴那巨大的威力近看是什么样子的。他在麦克风中所描述的内容，压过了引擎和风暴的轰鸣声，甚至没有看稿子，是非常优美的。置身于风眼中就像身处一个被云层环绕的圆形剧场。除了这种微弱的照明外，看不到太阳的迹象。
The whole surface of the ocean is undulating like some huge giant was shaking a carpet. Each huge wave seems to be dragging another along behind it. Wrapping up, in his studio, Murrow looked into the camera for his grand summation. And what he said is, in the eye of a hurricane. In the eye of a hurricane, you learn things other than of a scientific nature. You feel the puniness of man and his works.
整个海面都在起伏，就像某个巨大的庞然大物在抖动地毯。每一个巨浪似乎都在拖着另一个巨浪向前。结束时，在演播室里，默罗凝视着镜头作出了宏大的总结。他所说的是，在飓风眼中。在飓风眼中，你学到的不仅是科学性质的东西。你会感受到人类及其作品的渺小。
If a true definition of humility is ever written, it might well be written in the eye of a hurricane." Murrow's reporting helped the public feel the pure awe of being inside a giant hurricane. They could also see the enormous effort that went into tracking such a massive and dangerous phenomenon. A few months later, Congress set aside funds to establish the National Hurricane Research Project and its first director was a meteorologist named Robert Simpson, that same meteorologist
如果对谦逊下过真正的定义，它很可能会被写在飓风眼中。”默罗的报道帮助公众感受到了置身于巨大飓风内部的纯粹敬畏。他们还能看到追踪如此庞大且危险的现象所付出的巨大努力。几个月后，国会拨款成立了国家飓风研究项目，其首任导演是一位名叫罗伯特·辛普森的气象学家，也就是那位曾与默罗一同进行那次史诗般飞行的气象学家。
who was on that epic flight with Morrow. Over the next few decades, Simpson became the big name in hurricane research. In the early 1960s, he and his wife even led Project Storm Fury, where the U.S. government tried to weaken hurricanes by releasing silver iodide into them. That didn't work, obviously. Simpson and his colleagues were also trying to get a tighter grasp on hurricanes with enough time to warn the public about them. That meant communicating the forecast updates quickly and loudly.
在接下来的几十年里，辛普森成为了飓风研究领域的巨头。20世纪60年代初，他和妻子甚至领导了“风暴怒吼计划”（Project Storm Fury），当时美国政府试图通过向飓风中投放碘化银来削弱飓风。显然，那没有奏效。辛普森和他的同事们还试图更牢固地把握飓风，争取足够的时间向公众发出警告。这意味着需要快速、大声地传达预报更新。
Back then, warnings for hurricanes described them in vague terms, like either minor or major. There was a system of using flags along coastlines to tell people when was coming, but that was about it. Here's Simpson as director of the National Hurricane Center,
当时，飓风预警用模糊的术语来描述它们，比如“轻微”或“重大”。沿海地区曾有一种使用旗帜来告诉人们什么即将来临的系统，但也就仅此而已。这里是辛普森作为国家飓风中心主任，
describing his quest for a much more effective public alert system. You can't order a model off the shelf and put it into practice. But we can, through our modern technology, keep closer in touch with a hurricane, be sure that we're not deceived. In 1969, a hurricane named Camille
描述他对构建一个更有效的公众警报系统的追求。你无法直接从货架上订购一个模型并将其付诸实践。但我们可以通过现代科技，与飓风保持更密切的联系，确保我们不会被欺骗。1969年，一个名叫卡米尔的飓风
was stalled in the Gulf of Mexico. A lady called Camille supposedly headed toward the Florida panhandle, but like any lady, perfectly capable of changing her mind. Simpson didn't have a lot of information from the hurricane hunters until really late, because they were off chasing another storm in the Caribbean. He also didn't have a way to tell people, in simple terms, that this wasn't just going to be a hurricane. It was going to be a hurricane. It was going to be a hurricane.
停滞在墨西哥湾。一个名叫卡米尔的女士据说正朝着佛罗里达狭长地带移动，但正如任何女士一样，她完全有能力改变主意。辛普森直到很晚才从飓风猎人那里获得大量信息，因为他们当时正在加勒比海追逐另一场风暴。他也没有办法用简单的术语告诉人们，这不仅仅是一场飓风。这将是一场飓风。这将是一场飓风。
The National Hurricane Center put out alerts about Camille, which went beyond the simplistic language of existing warning systems. But those meteorologists ended up giving the public too much information. They described the storm as extremely dangerous, but also a tight little hurricane, which doesn't sound so scary, actually. And then they threw a lot of data at the public. They told people it had sustained winds of 150 or 160 miles per hour and it was moving 12 miles per hour. They reported that it had a barometric pressure of 26.81 and they compared that to a terrible hurricane in 1935 with a barometric pressure of 26.35
国家飓风中心发布了关于卡米尔的警报，超出了现有预警系统的简单化语言。但那些气象学家最终给公众提供了过多的信息。他们将风暴描述为“极其危险”，但也描述为“一个紧凑的小飓风”，这听效起来其实并不那么可怕。然后他们向公众抛出了大量数据。他们告诉人们，它持续风速达到每小时 150 或 160 英里，移动速度为每小时 12 英里。他们报告其气压为 26.81 英寸，并将其与 1935 年气压为 26.35 英寸的恐怖飓风进行了对比
inches. And I've been reporting this episode for months and I would really struggle in a crisis to tell you exactly what that comparison means. Camille's wind speeds are now thought to have been 175 miles per hour when it made landfall. We don't know exactly because the winds were so strong that they destroyed the equipment used to record them. This scene here on the Mississippi Gulf Coast is almost like an endless nightmare, almost like an endless one-act play with some sort of a macabre ending.
英寸。而且我报道这集节目已经好几个月了，如果在危机中，我要确切地告诉你这个对比意味着什么，我真的会感到很吃力。据信卡米尔登陆时的风速已达到每小时 175 英里。我们无法确切知道，因为风力实在太强，以至于摧毁了用于记录它们的设备。密西西比州墨西哥湾沿岸的这一幕几乎就像是一场无尽的噩梦，几乎就像是一场带有某种恐怖结局的无尽单幕剧。
Today we would call Camille a category five hurricane. It's one of only four category fives to have ever made landfall in the U.S. Camille killed 256 people. The storm washed away roads and made entire buildings just disappear. People came back to their communities and found piles of debris where their homes used to be. And this is my first hurricane. I didn't know enough to get out. My house was under 12 feet of water. And I hope I never see nothing like this again.
今天我们会称卡米尔为 5 级飓风。这是有史以来在美国登陆仅有的四个 5 级飓风之一。卡米尔夺去了 256 人的生命。风暴冲走了道路，让整栋整栋的建筑直接消失。人们回到自己的社区，在曾经是家的地方只找到了成堆的废墟。这是我的第一次飓风。我不知道应该撤离。我的房子被淹在 12 英尺深的水下。我希望我再也不会看到这样的景象了。
One woman was speaking to a news crew about her house not being where she left it. She turned around and saw it had been flung across the street, and she completely lost it. But mine was wrapped on the corner, and I don't even fit. Yandere! But mine was wrapped around the corner and I don't even fit. Yonder! That's my house!
一位女士正在对新闻摄制组谈论她的房子已经不在她离开时的位置了。她转过身看到房子被抛到了街对面，情绪彻底崩溃了。但我的被卷在拐角处，我甚至不合适。那边！但我的房子被卷在拐角处，我甚至不合适。那边！那是我的房子！
That grave in Yonder, that's my house! Bob Simpson talked about Camille in a Weather Channel documentary in 2012. We learned a lot from that. I learned a lot, both as to what kind of meteorology and what kind of language we should use that would convince the people it was time for them to go and not to argue about it at all. Touring the wreckage in the Gulf, Simpson heard over and over again that local authorities wanted to know how destructive a hurricane was going to be. Not just numbers and readings, but a quick sense of what those numbers would mean on
那边的那座坟墓，那是我的房子！鲍勃·辛普森在 2012 年的一部气象频道纪录片中谈到了卡米尔。我们从那次事件中学到了很多。我学到了很多，无论是关于我们应该使用什么样的气象学知识，还是应该使用什么样的语言，才能说服人们是时候离开了，而不是对此争论不休。在巡视海湾地区的残骸时，辛普森一次又一次地听到，地方当局希望知道飓风的破坏力到底有多大。不仅仅是数字和读数，而是要对这些数字在冲击时意味着什么有一个快速的感受。
impact. What people wanted was a key to understanding the potential aftermath. After the break, Bob Simpson teams up with a structural engineer to create the system for warning the public about deadly storms. In the wake of Hurricane Camille's devastation in 1969, one thing was clear to meteorologists like Bob Simpson. The world needed a system for rating storms that would help people understand the threat and how to respond. Someone else was already working on this, a structural engineer in Miami-Dade County
人们想要的是一把理解潜在后果的钥匙。休息过后，鲍勃·辛普森与一位结构工程师联手，创建了向公众发出致命风暴警告的系统。在 1969 年卡米尔飓风造成毁灭性打击之后，像鲍勃·辛普森这样的气象学家有一点是显而易见的。世界需要一个风暴评级系统，以帮助人们理解威胁以及如何应对。当时已经有人在从事这项工作了，他就是迈阿密-戴德县的一位结构工程师，
named Herb Saffer. He was developing a hurricane scale as part of a project for the United Nations, and it was based on structural damage from wind. It rated hurricanes one through five based on wind speeds and described what you'd expect from each level of intensity. Saffer sent his scale to the National Hurricane Center, where Bob Simpson made some tweaks,
名叫赫伯·萨菲尔。作为联合国项目的一部分，他正在开发一个飓风等级，该等级基于风力造成的结构破坏。它根据风速将飓风评为 1 到 5 级，并描述了你可以从每个强度级别中预期的影响。萨菲尔将他的等级发送给国家飓风中心，鲍勃·辛普森在那里做了一些调整，
adding risks from flooding and storm surge, which is how much the sea level will rise. And in 1974, the Safir-Simpson Hurricane Damage Scale was first published in a scientific journal, and the National Hurricane Center started using it for the public. It's just a couple of pages, actually. Exactly a couple of pages. Hugh Willoughby is the former director of NOAA's Hurricane Research Division. He remembers when the scale was first published. What the categories serve is it says, the wind is gonna blow really hard and you wanna do something about it.
增加了来自洪水和风暴潮（即海平面将上升多少）的风险。1974年，萨菲尔-辛普森飓风破坏等级首次在一份科学期刊上发表，国家飓风中心开始将其用于公众。其实只有几页纸而已。确实只有几页纸。休·威洛比是美国国家海洋和大气管理局（NOAA）飓风研究部的前主任。他记得该等级最初发表时的情形。这些等级的作用是告诉你：风会刮得非常大，你最好对此采取点行动。
The scale does a lot in those two pages. It goes to each of the five categories. It tells us that a category one is probably going to damage mobile homes that aren't anchored to the ground, for example. Stuff you leave outside are going to become projectiles. In a two, you're going to get some widespread power outages. You can expect windows to get blown out, and some signs are going to get blown away.
这个等级在那两页纸中发挥了巨大作用。它涵盖了全部五个级别。它告诉我们，1 级可能会损坏没有锚定在地面上的移动房屋，例如。你留在外面的东西会变成抛射物。在 2 级时，你会遭遇大面积停电。你可以预见到窗户会被吹碎，一些路标会被吹走。
A category three is where things start to get really serious, with devastating damage. Trees will get uprooted or snapped, and power outages could last for weeks. The scale tells us that category 4 or above is going to be catastrophic. Roofs are going to come off. Some walls might too. And category 5 hurricanes are relatively rare. Category 5 means, holy Toledo, we better do something. Cat 5s will bring power outages for months. The tops of industrial buildings will get swept off.
3 级则是事情开始变得真正严重、造成破坏性损害的时候。树木会被连根拔起或折断，停电可能会持续数周。该等级告诉我们，4 级或以上将是灾难性的。屋顶会被掀翻。有些墙壁也可能会塌。而 5 级飓风相对罕见。5 级意味着：天哪，我们最好采取行动。5 级会带来持续数月的停电。工业建筑的顶部会被彻底刮飞。
Whole structures are going to get blown away. The categories don't ask you to know about barometric pressure. They don't ask you to think about whether these wind speeds are stronger than the wind speeds of the last hurricane your roof survived. The scale communicates exactly five numbers. One to five. That's it.
整个结构都会被吹走。这些等级并不要求你了解气压。它们不要求你去思考这些风速是否比你家屋顶挺过的上一场飓风的风速更大。这个等级传达了刚好五个数字。1 到 5。就是这样。
You know, here's the problem. 100 knots of wind sounds like a lot of wind. 150 knots of wind sounds like a lot of wind. Hugh Willoughby likes to talk in knots, by the way. 100 knots is like 115 miles per hour, 150 is like 172. That's how meteorologists think about hurricanes in these big numbers. But imagine using that to warn the public? That's way too much math in the middle of a crisis. And Saffir-Simpson scale gets us away from there. It's really useful for getting a single mom and her two kids to evacuate. For 50 years, we've had categories one to five to keep things simple. The reasoning was it wasn't
你知道，问题在于。100 节的风速听起来像是很大的风。150 节的风速听起来像是很大的风。顺便说一句，休·威洛比喜欢用“节”来交谈。100 节大约是每小时 115 英里，150 节大约是 172 英里。这就是气象学家用这些庞大数字思考飓风的方式。但想象一下用这个来警告公众？在危机当中，这涉及的数学计算实在太多了。而萨菲尔-辛普森等级让我们摆脱了这一点。它对于说服一个单亲妈妈带着两个孩子撤离非常有用。50 年来，我们一直拥有 1 到 5 级来保持事情的简单明了。理由是，没有必要
necessary to go any higher. It's all about the property damage you can expect from a hurricane. There's a famous quote, famous to meteorologists that is, from Bob Simpson from a hurricane. There's a famous quote, famous to meteorologists, that is, from Bob Simpson from a print interview he gave in 1991. He stuck to the scale only being about hurricane damage to buildings and infrastructure. Simpson explained that any storm with winds above 156 miles per hour or so, which is a category 5, would be so awful, so devastating for buildings, that it's a catastrophe no matter what.
提升到更高。这完全取决于你可以从飓风中预期的财产损失。有一句名言，对气象学家来说很有名，出自鲍勃·辛普森在 1991 年接受的一家平面媒体采访。他坚持认为该等级仅涉及飓风对建筑物和基础设施的破坏。辛普森解释说，任何风速超过每小时 156 英里左右的风暴（即 5 级）都会非常糟糕，对建筑物具有极大的破坏性，无论如何这都是一场灾难。
He said, quote, I think it's immaterial. That's the reason why we didn't try to go any higher than that anyway. End quote. Basically, once a building is totally destroyed, you can't get more destroyed. And an open-ended five accounts for that. But lately there have been calls to change the scale anyway. for that. But lately, there have been calls to change the scale anyway. Hurricane Dorian has sustained winds right now of 185 miles per hour with gusts above 200. And according to the...
他说，原话是：“我认为这无关紧要。这就是为什么我们无论如何都没有试图做得更高。”原话引毕。基本上，一旦一座建筑物被完全摧毁，你就无法再将它更彻底地摧毁了。而一个开放式的 5 级正好说明了这一点。但最近还是有人呼吁改变这个等级。说明了这一点。但最近，还是有人呼吁改变这个等级。多利安飓风目前的持续风速为每小时 185 英里，阵风超过 200 英里。根据……
Hurricane Dorian sat on top of the Bahamas in 2019, dumping rain for 48 hours. Although Dorian was technically designated a category five, everyone who saw it thought it was way bigger than a five. And it was so intense that it introduced this terrifying question into the world. Not just for meteorologists or researchers, but for everyone. A question about how we talk about hurricanes and even how we think about them. As we see more catastrophic hurricanes like Dorian, should scientists consider adding a category six to the hurricane scale? CBS News... A category six to the hurricane scale?
2019年，多利安飓风盘旋在巴哈马群岛上空，倾盆大雨下了 48 小时。尽管多利安在技术上被指定为 5 级，但所有看到它的人都认为它远大于 5 级。它是如此猛烈，以至于在这个世界上引入了一个可怕的问题。不仅仅是对气象学家或研究人员而言，而是对所有人。一个关于我们如何谈论飓风甚至如何思考飓风的问题。当我们看到更多像多利安这样灾难性的飓风时，科学家们是否应该考虑在飓风等级中增加一个 6 级？哥伦比亚广播公司新闻……在飓风等级中增加一个 6 级？
A category six to capture how bad things are getting. Scientists say climate change means stronger storms are going to be more frequent and that they're likely to intensify a lot more quickly. That's true in the Pacific, where hurricanes are called typhoons or super typhoons. That's also true of hurricanes in the Atlantic. Yes, we have seen a rash of huge hurricanes in the past. There were a bunch of them in the early 20th century. But in the last 50 years, the U.S. has been hit by 10 hurricanes that were category four or five. And seven of those giant storms have happened just since 2017.
增加一个 6 级来反映情况变得有多糟糕。科学家表示，气候变化意味着更强的风暴将更加频繁，并且它们可能会以更快的速度加剧。太平洋地区就是如此，那里的飓风被称为台风或超级台风。大西洋的飓风也是如此。是的，我们过去见过一连串巨大的飓风。20 世纪初曾出现过一堆。但在过去的 50 年里，美国遭受了 10 次 4 级或 5 级飓风的袭击。其中七场巨大的风暴仅自 2017 年以来就发生了。
It's like we're seeing a catastrophic hurricane nearly every year. Hurricane Harvey, state of emergency. Tonight, Maria's direct hit, devastating Puerto Rico. Tonight, across Texas and Louisiana, Hurricane Laura's message, loud and clear. Hurricane Ian making history as it's making landfall, a super destructive, very dangerous phase in this category.
这就像我们几乎每年都能看到一场灾难性的飓风。飓风哈维，进入紧急状态。今晚，玛丽亚直接袭击，重创波多黎各。今晚，在德克萨斯州和路易斯安那州，飓风劳拉的信息响亮而清晰。飓风伊恩正在创造历史，因为它在登陆，这是该等级中一个极具破坏性、非常危险的阶段。
This worsening trend is why some meteorologists have started to suggest expanding the Saffir Simpson scale to include a category 6. That conversation spilled out into the open recently with a journal article that considered what it would mean to add a cat 6. It got a ton of press attention. The paper was called the growing inadequacy of an open-ended Saffir-Simpson hurricane wind scale in a warming world. The argument is that category 5 has no top.
这种恶化的趋势正是为什么一些气象学家开始建议将萨菲尔-辛普森等级扩大到包括 6 级的原因。最近，这种讨论在一篇考虑增加 6 级意味着什么的期刊文章中公开化了。它获得了大量的媒体关注。这篇论文题为《在一个变暖的世界中，开放式萨菲尔-辛普森飓风风力等级日益不足》。其论点是 5 级没有上限。
It starts at 157 miles per hour, sustained speed. But where does it stop? This is Richard Olson, director of the Extreme Events Institute and the International Hurricane Research Center. Home of the wall of wind. And he's one of the people who thinks it's really time to talk about updating the scale
它从每小时 157 英里的持续风速开始。但它在哪里停下来？这是理查德·奥尔森，极端事件研究所兼国际飓风研究中心主任。风墙的所在地。他也是认为现在确实是时候讨论更新这个等级
and maybe expanding it to include a category six. You look at the science and the science says, higher number of more intense storms. Okay, well, let's think about that in terms of a scale that was developed 50 years ago. It's time to have that debate. He remembers watching Dorian's path in 2019, when it looked like that hurricane would hit South Florida. It was going to be like Andrew all over again, only worse. That brought it home. It was like a lightning bolt right between my eyes. And I said, okay, I don't know how to describe to the media what it feels like to be looking at sustained winds of 185 miles an hour, less than 30 hours from my house.
并可能将其扩大到包括 6 级的人之一。你看看科学，科学表明，更强烈的风暴数量会更多。好吧，让我们结合 50 年前制定的等级来思考这个问题。是时候展开这场辩论了。他记得在 2019 年观看多利安的路径时，当时看起来那场飓风将袭击南佛罗里达。那将是又一次安德鲁风暴重演，甚至更糟。这让他感同身受。这就像一道闪电直击我的双眼。我说，好吧，我不知道该如何向媒体形容，直面距离我家不到 30 小时、持续风速达到每小时 185 英里的风暴是什么感觉。
Climate change has forced scientists to make other adjustments to their extreme weather warning systems. The Australian Bureau of Meteorology added two new colors, pink and purple, to their maps to convey record-breaking heat. So maybe a six would expand our vocabulary for this greater risk and drive home the urgency of climate change. And the Saffir-Simpson Hurricane Scale is from 1974. Maybe it could use an update.
气候变化迫使科学家对其极端天气预警系统做出其他调整。澳大利亚气象局在地图上添加了两种新颜色——粉色和紫色——来传达破纪录的高温。所以也许一个 6 级会扩大我们应对这种更大风险的词汇量，并坚定传达气候变化的紧迫性。而萨菲尔-辛普森飓风等级自 1974 年起就存在了。或许它确实需要更新。
It describes damage as though all structures are created equal. But of course that isn't true. Some areas have more vulnerable infrastructure than others. You could have a Category 2 storm that gives you the long-term power outages of a Category 5. Besides, a lot has changed about how we build stuff. Maybe Bob Simpson's reasoning that it's all the same damage after five just isn't true anymore.
它对破坏的描述就好像所有建筑生而平等一样。但事实当然并非如此。有些地区的基础设施比其他地区更脆弱。你可能会遭遇一场 2 级风暴，却带来 5 级风暴那样的长期停电。此外，我们建造东西的方式已经发生了很大变化。也许鲍勃·辛普森关于“过 5 级之后破坏都一样”的推论现在已经不再成立了。
It's not the same built environment as it was 30, 40 years ago. Fifty even. I can't believe that that's absolutely true. Yes, now I feel really old. Okay. It just says to me that we need to have the academic government open kind of debate. But the National Hurricane Center, which administers the scale and is in charge of categorizing hurricanes, isn't keen on adding a six to Saffir-Simpson. There's a fear in the scientific community that expanding it would do more harm than good.
这里的建筑环境已经与 30、40 年前不同了。甚至 50 年前。我无法相信那是绝对正确的。好吧，现在我真的觉得自己老了。好吧。这对我来说只是意味着我们需要开展学术界与政府公开形式的辩论。但负责管理该等级并负责飓风分类的国家飓风中心并不热衷于在萨菲尔-辛普森中增加 6 级。科学界有一种担忧，即扩大它会弊大于利。
And that's less about screws and roofs than it is about people, what people will do when they're told about risks. Many don't evacuate for a four or five, sometimes because they can't, sometimes because they don't want to. So if six becomes the highest, what would that mean for the public's response?
这与其说关乎螺丝和屋顶，不如说关乎人，关乎人们在被告知风险时会做出什么反应。许多人面对 4 级或 5 级时并不撤离，有时是因为他们不能，有时是因为他们不想。因此，如果 6 级成为最高级别，这对公众的反应意味着什么？
It's still hard to understand, you know, what are we trying to achieve with calling something category 6? Is it meant to get people to do something different than they should be doing with F4 and F5? This is Robbie Berg, the warning coordination meteorologist for the National Hurricane Center. The official answer from the NHC right now is no to a six. And then I think the next question is, where does it stop? Would they next have to add a seven? Some of the social science has actually shown that
你知道，我们仍然很难理解，将某物称为 6 级，我们到底想达到什么目的？它是为了让人们做出与面对 F4 和 F5 时不同的行动吗？这是罗比·伯格，国家飓风中心的预警协调气象学家。国家飓风中心目前给出的官方答案是对 6 级说不。然后我认为接下来的问题是，它在哪里停下来？接下来他们是不是还得增加 7 级？一些社会科学研究实际上表明，
when you have too many categories in a scale or too many, say, colors on a map, it actually becomes harder and harder for people to interpret that because we can't... In our minds, it's very hard to deal with too many categories. Five is a very good, nice round number that the human mind can absorb and understand. And so I'll just say, you know, our point of view is that fours and fives are still catastrophic. What more is there than that? And nobody's been able to answer that. There's not another word beyond catastrophic that can categorize what that
当你等级中的分类太多，或者地图上的颜色太多时，人们解读起来实际上会变得越来越难，因为我们无法……在我们的脑海中，处理太多的分类是非常困难的。5 是一个非常好的、漂亮的整数，人脑可以吸收和理解。所以我会说，你知道，我们的观点是，4 级和 5 级仍然是灾难性的。除此之外还有什么？没有人能够给出答案。除了“灾难性”之外，没有别的词可以对这种破坏进行分类。
damage would be. Totally understand that and totally understand why they're saying, let's not run off in this direction too quickly. Again, this is Richard Olson, who directs the International Hurricane Research Center. But I just go back to the fact that if we're seeing storms in the 180s or higher, I don't want to be playing catch up with nature. So Olson has been thinking about what kind of research the wall of wind can contribute to the debate.
完全理解这一点，也完全理解他们为什么会说，让我们不要太快朝着这个方向发展。再次说明，这是理查德·奥尔森，国际飓风研究中心的负责人。但我还是要回到这个事实：如果我们看到风速达到 180 英里甚至更高风力的风暴，我可不想跟在大自然后面疲于奔命。因此，奥尔森一直在思考风墙可以为这场辩论贡献什么样的研究。
We need to know more, he says, about what happens to our infrastructure at the further reaches of a five. So the issue for us is testing at all levels, all intensities of a storm. We have to be thinking about a facility that goes beyond the current capabilities of the wall of wind. That's why they've gotten a big government grant to figure out how to build a bigger, more beefed up lab.
他说，我们需要更多地了解，当风暴达到 5 级的极端极限时，我们的基础设施会发生什么。所以对我们来说，问题在于测试风暴的所有级别、所有强度。我们必须考虑建立一个超越风墙当前能力的设施。这就是为什么他们获得了政府的一笔巨资，来研究如何建造一个更大、更强化的实验室。
One that will go up to 200 miles per hour and have a big water tank to simulate storm surge and waves too. It'd be quite, quite large. Think of the wall of wind ten times the size probably. They want to simulate the whole hurricane, not just the wind part, in order to figure out how buildings and infrastructure might be able to withstand stronger storms. And that kind of facility would actually do something that goes beyond Saffir-Simpson, which points to what may be the scale's single biggest flaw.
这种风洞时速可达每小时200英里，还配有一个大型水箱，用来模拟风暴潮和巨浪。它会非常非常大。想象一下，风墙的尺寸可能是原来的十倍。他们想要模拟整个飓风，而不只是风的部分，以便弄清楚建筑物和基础设施如何能够承受更强的风暴。这种设施实际上可以做一些超越萨菲尔-辛普森等级的事情，这也指出了该等级可能存在的最大缺陷。
It doesn't at all account for water. It doesn't consider how much rainfall a hurricane might cause, or the expected storm surge, which is the amount of ocean water that gets pushed inland by strong winds beyond what you'd get from a normal tide. The relationship between wind speeds and storm surge isn't so simple. There are lots of complicating factors, like the angle of approach to the coast or what the continental shelf is like there, which is why the National Hurricane Center, which administers the scale, stripped water out of the scale in 2010. And yet… Most people who die in hurricanes drown.
它完全没有把水算进去。它没有考虑飓风可能带来的降雨量，也没有考虑预计的风暴潮，也就是强风将海水推向内陆、超出正常潮汐的量。风速和风暴潮之间的关系并不那么简单。这其中有很多复杂的因素，比如接近海岸的角度或当地的大陆架是什么样的，这就是为什么管理该等级的国家飓风中心在2010年将水从该等级中剔除了。然而……在飓风中丧生的大多数人都被淹死了。
Moving water, it probably accounts for two-thirds of the property damage and almost all of the deaths. Well, 80% of the deaths. And that's what we need to worry about. One way to address that would be to introduce an additional scale to warn people about flooding risk and storm surge. That would save more lives.
流动的水，它可能占了财产损失的三分之二和几乎所有的死亡人数。嗯，占了死亡人数的80%。这才是我们需要担心的。解决这个问题的一个方法是引入一个额外的等级，来警告人们洪水风险和风暴潮。那样会挽救更多人的生命。
The forecasters take it personally when somebody gets killed. They just don't like it at all. And rightly so. And the people that get drowned don't like it at all. And rightly so. And the people that get drowned don't like it either. And in fact, this is something the National Hurricane Center, the NHC, really struggles with when it comes to the Saffir-Simpson. It's a simple shorthand, but in some ways, it's too simple. It helps us to communicate that obviously a storm is strong
当有人丧生时，预报员们会认为是自己的责任。他们非常不喜欢这样。这是理所当然的。而被淹死的人也绝对不愿意这样。这也是理所当然的。而被淹死的人同样也不喜欢这样。事实上，这也是国家飓风中心（NHC）在面对萨菲尔-辛普森等级时非常纠结的事情。它是一种简单的速记法，但在某些方面，它又过于简单了。它帮助我们传达这样一个明显的信息，即风暴非常强烈
when it gets to be three, four, five, but we have really started to shy away from using it for everything. Robbie Berg with the NHC says it was a big problem during Hurricane Florence in 2018. Florence had gotten strong. It got to a major hurricane strength. It was reaching or heading toward North Carolina and it began to weaken a little bit as it was approaching the coast. It weakened so much that it was no longer technically a hurricane. But the hazards with the storm, the rainfall we were expecting, the storm surge we
当风暴达到三级、四级、五级时，但我们确实已经开始回避在所有事情上都使用它。国家飓风中心的罗比·伯格（Robbie Berg）表示，这在2018年的飓风“佛罗伦萨”期间是一个大问题。佛罗伦萨当时变得很强。它达到了大型飓风的强度。它当时正在接近或朝着北卡罗来纳州移动，在接近海岸时开始稍微减弱。它减弱得如此厉害，以至于在技术上不再是飓风。但是风暴带来的灾难、我们预期的降雨、我们预期的风暴潮
were expecting was not going to change. It didn't matter that the storm was weakening. The rainfall and the surge were still going to be very bad. So we made a concerted effort that in our communications, we did not say the storm is weakening. They wanted people to focus on the risks of storm surge. And what you know is that as soon as we sent out the advisory, we started getting notices on our phone. And what do you think the headlines were? It's weakening. It's weakening. It's downgraded to category one. So the message is that we were intentionally trying to avoid,
并没有改变。风暴在减弱并不重要。降雨和风暴潮仍然会非常糟糕。因此我们做出了一致的努力，在我们的交流中，我们没有说风暴在减弱。他们希望人们关注风暴潮的风险。你知道的，就在我们发出警报后不久，我们的手机上就开始收到通知。你认为头条新闻是什么？它在减弱。它在减弱。它已经降级为一级。所以我们原本刻意想要避免的信息，
they were still getting out there in the media because journalists were writing stories and that's what they were attached to is the wind speed. Yeah, we suck. That's not what I'm saying at all. It's just that- No, no, I'll say it. There's just, there's no one way
仍然出现在媒体上，因为记者们在写报道，而他们所关注的正是风速。是的，我们糟透了。我根本不是这个意思。只是——不，不，我来明说吧。根本没有哪一种方法
that's going to fix the problem entirely. So really our, our, our goal is to find ways that are going to serve the most number of the population, that the most number of people are going to understand. Um, and that's just a very tricky place to get to. It won't surprise you to hear that the warming climate is going to bring more and more storms. Forecasters say 2024 will be a hyperactive hurricane season, with an abnormally high number of storms heading the North Atlantic. And we're going into this season with extremely imperfect tools for communicating the risk.
能彻底解决这个问题。所以实际上我们的目标是找到能够服务最多人口、能让最多人理解的方法。嗯，要达到这一点非常棘手。听到气候变暖将带来越来越多的风暴，你不会感到惊讶。预报员表示，2024年将是一个超活跃的飓风季，前往北大西洋的风暴数量异常之多。我们在进入这个季节时，用于传达风险的工具极其不完美。
Again, here's Hugh Willoughby. You know, another thing. We have hurricane watches and hurricane warnings. Both begin with W, they're about the same length. You know, there ought to be more psychological distance between them. I agree. I can never tell what the difference is. Are they not just synonyms? Right. Yeah, and that's... Thank you. I thought I was really stupid. Well, no. You want the social scientists, the anthropologists, the communicators, all these people, you want them talking to the people who do the meteorology so
再次有请休·威로比（Hugh Willoughby）。你知道，还有一件事。我们有飓风观察（hurricane watches）和飓风警告（hurricane warnings）。两者都以W开头，长度也差不多。你知道，它们之间应该有更多的心理距离。我同意。我从来分不清有什么区别。它们不只是同义词吗？对。是的，那……谢谢你。我以为自己真的很蠢。嗯，不。你需要社会学家、人类学家、传播学者，所有这些人，你需要让他们与气象工作者交流，以便
that you communicate it right. The Category 6 debate is what got me interested in the history of how we've assessed hurricanes and in the Saffir-Simpson scale specifically. There have been a lot of headlines about expanding the scale to 6. There's something visceral about that idea that gets people's attention. And I totally get it. I feel it too. It's both terrifying and compelling. Like things are so bad, maybe we just need to find a new way to talk about this level
你能够正确地传达信息。关于六级飓风的争论让我对我们评估飓风的历史产生了兴趣，尤其是对萨菲尔-辛普森等级。有很多关于将等级扩大到6级的头条新闻。这个想法有一种本能的力量，能引起人们的注意。我完全理解。我也深有同感。它既可怕又引人注目。就像情况太糟了，也许我们只是需要找到一种新方法来谈论这种程度的糟糕。
of bad. It feels to me like we're living in six times. Not just with climate change, but with wars, with failing democracies, with a global health pandemic, and on and on. But there's way less public discussion, I've found, about the fact that the scale doesn't say anything about the deadly risk from water, or even about the urgent need to update our building codes along the coast. When you think about it, those seem like pretty major blind spots.
我感觉我们正生活在一个六级的时代。不仅是气候变化，还有战争、走向失败的民主制度、全球健康大流行，等等等等。但我发现，公众对此类讨论要少得多：该等级没有说明来自水的致命风险，甚至没有提到我们在海岸沿线更新建筑规范的紧迫需求。仔细想想，这些似乎是相当大的盲点。
And what everyone can agree on is that we've got to address those shortcomings. As storms get more intense and more frequent, we need a system that rises to the occasion. And not just another word for catastrophe. 99% Invisible was produced this week by Alana Casanova-Bergess, edited by Christopher Johnson, mixed by Martin Gonzalez, music by Swan Real, fact-checking by Graham Hayesha. Special thanks this week to Jeff Masters, Zach Rosen, the Edward R. Murrow collection at the Tufts Archives, and Jenny Lawton. Cathy Tu is our executive producer, Kurt Kolstad is the digital director. Delaney Hall is our senior editor.
每个人都同意的是，我们必须解决这些缺点。随着风暴变得更加强烈和频繁，我们需要一个能够应对挑战的系统。而不仅仅是灾难的另一个代名词。《99%隐形》本周由阿拉娜·卡萨诺瓦-伯格斯（Alana Casanova-Bergess）制作，克里斯托弗·约翰逊（Christopher Johnson）编辑，马丁·冈萨雷斯（Martin Gonzalez）混音，天鹅真实乐团（Swan Real）配乐，格雷厄姆·海沙（Graham Hayesha）核实事实。本周特别鸣谢杰夫·马斯特斯（Jeff Masters）、扎克·罗森（Zach Rosen）、塔夫茨档案馆（Tufts Archives）的爱德华·R·莫罗（Edward R. Murrow）藏品以及珍妮·劳顿（Jenny Lawton）。凯茜·图（Cathy Tu）是我们的执行制片人，库尔特·科尔斯塔德（Kurt Kolstad）是数字总监。德兰尼·霍尔（Delaney Hall）是我们的高级编辑。
The rest of the team includes Chris Berube, Sarah Bake, Jason de Leon, Emmett Fitzgerald, Gabriella Gladney, Vivian Ley, Lash Madon, Jacob Maldonado-Medina, Nina Pautuck, Kelly Prime, Joe Rosenberg, and me, Roman Mars. Nikita Apte is our intern. The 99% of his logo was created by Stephen Lawrence. We are part of the Stitcher and SiriusXM podcast family, now headquartered six blocks north in the Pandora building. And beautiful. Uptown. Oakland, California. You can find us on all the usual social media sites as well as our own brand new Discord server. There are like almost 4,000 people talking about architecture, talking about the power broker, talking about all kinds of fun
团队的其他成员包括克里斯·贝鲁贝（Chris Berube）、莎拉·贝克（Sarah Bake）、杰森·德·莱昂（Jason de Leon）、埃米特·菲茨杰拉德（Emmett Fitzgerald）、加布里埃拉·格拉德尼（Gabriella Gladney）、维维安·莱（Vivian Ley）、拉什·马顿（Lash Madon）、雅各布·马尔多纳多-梅迪纳（Jacob Maldonado-Medina）、尼娜·保图克（Nina Pautuck）、凯利·普赖姆（Kelly Prime）、乔·罗森博格（Joe Rosenberg），以及我，罗曼·马尔斯（Roman Mars）。尼基塔·阿普特（Nikita Apte）是我们的实习生。99%的标志由斯蒂芬·劳伦斯（Stephen Lawrence）创作。我们是Stitcher和SiriusXM播客大家庭的一员，现在总部设在潘多拉大楼以北六个街区。美丽。上城区。加利福尼亚州奥克兰。你可以在所有常见的社交媒体网站以及我们全新的Discord服务器上找到我们。那里有将近4,000人在讨论建筑、讨论《权力掮客》、讨论各种好玩的事情
things. Please join us there. There's a link the power broker, talking about all kinds of fun things. Please join us there. There's a link to that as well as every past episode of 99PI at 99PI.org. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
请加入我们。在99PI.org上有一个指向该服务器以及99PI每一期往期节目的链接。本期节目暂无评论。点击转录文本中的任意句子即可发表评论。